what it was it's not that it was a bad
campaign per se but people were
expecting like I said at the time after
that 2020 showing I said back then I go
I think Craig could end up being the
best thing
that happens to Halo Infinity because
you know if it wasn't for Craig I don't
know if they would have delayed it
because that's a good point damn because
when Satan came in right around Craig
because you've got to remember that demo
you cannot tell me that demo didn't get
seen by Bonnie you can't tell me that
demo didn't get seen
probably by Phil like that a lot of
higher ups would have seen that demo and
said yep ship it
all good
so they all thought
I assume that it looked pretty good
that's what happens when you're dancing
in the mirror by yourself